well the holidays are over but the
travel headaches really continue for so
many passengers thousands of flights
were canceled or delayed all across the
country leaving passengers wondering
when they're going to get home christian
casadas joining us live in studio with
some advice for travelers kristin well
denise patience is what many passengers
tell us is needed as they try to make
their way home from the new year's day
holiday now as of six o'clock there have
been 133 delays and 36 cancellations at
reid international that's according to
flightaware and things don't seem to be
getting any better
just here hoping for the best it's been
a holiday to remember for francesca and
her group of friends from alaska they
were hoping for a fabulous new year's in
las vegas but instead it's been a series
of headaches our
friend's flight got canceled she had to
leave two days early in order to even
make it here by the scheduled time of
our
hotel reservation and then
our checked bags were having problems
but they're not alone thousands more are
dealing with similar problems around the
country after a winter storm slammed the
east coast and impacted air travel one
hour delay
any
reason i mean did they say anything
they didn't
just keeping my fingers crossed and i
can deal with that hopefully it doesn't
get to be a lot longer flight tracking
website flightaware reporting more than
30 flights were canceled on monday and
over 80 flights were delayed at reid
international omicron also causing a
shortage in flight crews and slowing
travel i can't
return to my country because i
have the test the copy test and i don't
receive the result
and
i can't travel i'm scared yeah i'm
nervous so i'm just praying for the best
all right if your flight was one of
those impacted the best advice is to
contact your airline directly now check
for updates and options because remember
not all airlines accommodate passengers
automatically christian casa is live
local now